so the open borders crisis is not just
affecting Texas and Arizona and
California two weeks ago hundreds of
migrants landed in the Florida Keys so
many arrived they shut down a national
park there are no signs that this
invasion is going to stop so the
governor of Florida Ron DeSantis has
just activated the Florida National
Guard he's also announced he's
considering another major step to secure
this country's Borders or at least his
State's borders he says he's weighing a
band to prevent China from purchasing
real estate in Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis of Florida joins us now to
explain Governor thanks so much for
coming on so you're activating the
National Guard what will they do
so they've been uh heavy in this ever
since we activated Tucker over the last
week to 10 days basically Biden is
leaving the Coast Guard out to dry he's
not sending any more vessels any more
support they don't have enough to
intercept all the boats that are trying
to come primarily from Cuba but also
from Haiti so what we're doing with our
assets we're out there in the Florida
Straits we're using reconnaissance we
were alerting to the Coast Guard when
boats are there we're stopping boats and
then the Coast Guard are picking these
folks up and here's the thing Tucker you
know we think that some of this is
absolutely being orchestrated by the
Cuban government we think there's a lot
of human smuggling going on so not only
is this not good for the Florida Keys to
have people dumped on on their property
some of these people that are on these
boats are being mistreated and so I
think we've seen a decline in the number
of vessels that are in the water we have
not had as many Landings actually very
few uh lately so it is working as a
deterrent but it's our sense that
they're going to start trying to change
their tactics so we're going to be
watching and we're going to be
responding in kind
the fact that you're willing to do this
is itself a deterrent to Smugglers of
course so one of the the challenges in
Florida so many people have moved here
that real estate prices have gotten
really high
foreign countries trying to specifically
buying up more real estate doesn't help
any American this is happening in other
states as well what is your idea for
dealing with this
we want no CCP land purchases and
obviously they're not going to do it
directly they will have shell companies
so we're going to have to have a system
in place to scrutinize this but why
would we want them buying Farmland they
had very little Farmland in the United
States even 10 years ago now they have
significant Holdings not as much in
Florida but you do have it in other
parts of the country why would we want
the CCP to own land near a military base
our own critical infrastructure so we're
looking for a flat van and so we're
going to work with the Florida
legislature to get that done Tucker
American policy makers for a generation
have been empowering the CCP they said
it would end up working out China will
become a democracy in fact this is a
very serious threat to our country why
would we want them to have even more
influence over American society than
they already do
so very short question Governor these
two things using the National Guard to
protect the borders and preventing a
hostile foreign Nation from buying up
Farmland these are things a lot of other
states can be doing but aren't doing
were they hard for you to do is this
super hard
well the National Guard we control I
mean it's we're putting resources you
know we have a big budget surplus Tucker
so we can do that and people are very
happy you know we're taking care of the
vessels that are landing otherwise the
homeowners would have to pay 2500 a pop
so we're stepping in where the federal
government's failing I think more states
can do it Tucker but honestly we should
not have to be doing this the federal
government should be taking care of the
immigration issue and they should be
taking care of the CCP issue with this
Administration we know neither of those
two things are going to happen
we're grateful you're doing it thank you
Governor understands of Florida
appreciate it subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight